la libra libanesa alcanzó ayer otro
mínimo histórico llegando a cotizar a
140.000 libras libanesas por un dólar lo
que provocó el caos y manifestaciones
durante varias horas en las principales
ciudades del Líbano donde se cortaron
carreteras Y tuvo que intervenir el
ejército esta mañana los libaneses
hartos de no poder sacar su dinero por
el corralito impuesto por los bancos y
viendo como cada día son más Pobres han
vuelto a salir a las calles de beirut
esta vez al palacio de gobierno para
exigir de una vez que haya un gobierno
para que se puedan aplicar nuevas leyes
y pueda haber realmente un rescate
económico los libaneses se han
enfrentado a las fuerzas de seguridad
que han respondido con gases
lacrimógenos Y es que están hartos
hartos de que cada día vean que su
moneda cada vez vale menos y cada día
tengan que sufrir y que seguir buscando
la manera de poder sobrevivir porque la
hiperinflación histórica que hay en el
país está haciendo que ni siquiera la
gente pueda ir a la compra a comprar los
productos básicos o que las farmacias
por ejemplo hayan tenido casi
prácticamente que acabar con sus
suministros